story is up to 22 times more memorable
than facts alone what is your signature
story this is a story that my student
Robert shot wanna shared with me it was
a story about his best friend Sameer
Bhatia who's a social entrepreneur a
graduate at Stanford University he met
and fell in love with a girl named Rina
and Reena and Samir were traveling in
India when he started to feel hot and
feverish and he went to the hospital and
he was immediately diagnosed with
leukemia he called Robert and Robert was
shocked he talked to the doctors and he
learned that the best chance of survival
was to find a match in the bone marrow
registry but there were no matches in
the registry for Sameer and worse the
odds of finding a match for Sameer were
1 and 20,000 so Robert figured that if
the odds were 1 in 20,000 what they
should do was run bone marrow drives and
try and get 20,000 South Asians into the
registry the only problem they had weeks
to get this done so Robert had a choice
he could send people data about the dire
odds for Sameer and also details about
the bone marrow registry or he could
share a story he chose to share that
story and he shared that story about
Sameer in a way that was so personal
rather than analytical that anyone who
read this story or heard this story felt
connected to Sameer and the call to
action was abundantly clear first get
tested and get yourself into the bone
marrow registry second share this story
with 10 of your friends and ask them to
share the same story with 10 of theirs
and third come to the Sameer website to
learn more about how you can help and
the story spread and Alette to 470 bone
marrow drives run twenty four thousand
six hundred and eleven South Asians
registered into the bone marrow registry
in 11 short weeks and in that time a
perfect match was found for Samir
ultimately and tragically Samir passed
on though three months later as some of
you may know the odds of survival are as
high as 80% if a perfect match is found
immediately but they can be as low as
40% if that is not the case and the
reason I share this story is that out of
the twenty four thousand six hundred
eleven people who registered for Samir
two hundred and sixty six people who
needed a bone marrow match were matched
with people in that group in just one
year alone that's 266 people who don't
just have the gift of hope they have the
gift of time so listening to Robert's
story made me want to understand the
research around story when and why is
story effective in persuasion and moving
people toward your goals so when most of
us advocate for ideas we think of a
compelling argument a fact or a figure
neuroscience research shows that in fact
our brains are not hardwired to
understand logic or retain facts for
very long our brain is in fact wired to
understand and retain stories in one
study a researchers asked students in a
classroom to make a one-minute pitch to
their cohort on average a typical
student used 2.5 statistics in their
pitch and only one out of 10 students
actually worked in a story ten minutes
later the researcher asked everyone to
take out a piece of paper and write down
everything they remembered about each
pitch only 5% of the people surveyed
actually cited a statistic 63 percent
remembered the story
a story is a connected set of events
with the beginning a middle and an end
and it's a journey that moves the
listener and when the listener goes on
that journey they feel different and the
result is persuasion and sometimes
action stories are not facts figures or
less and yet when facts and figures are
interwoven into a story it can pull at
the audience both intellectually as well
as emotionally now stories can be short
140 characters like a tweet or they
could be longer like a book or a movie
the best story is well told can be told
in multiple forms and at multiple
lengths stories are important for three
reasons first stories shape how others
see you second stories are tools of
power and third stories persuade so
first stories shape how other CEO
research shows that the stories that
others tell about you influence how they
see you whether they want to hire you
and whether they want to buy from you in
one study researchers asked people to
list the stories that others told about
that the results showed that 36% of the
people surveyed didn't know what stories
others told about them the remaining
said something very interesting that is
the more stories they listed that others
told about them the happier they felt in
the more confident they felt and when
the stories that others told about them
were positive or funny the more liked
they felt and when those stories
connoted power or impact the more
respected they felt second stories are
tools of power when you tell a story
people slow down and they listen and
listening is a form of power as well
listening to others share their stories
to you in
one exercise people were asked to watch
individuals in a meeting and they were
asked to infer how much power did each
individual in that meeting have so these
individuals watch the people in the
meeting and noted who shared stories and
who was listening the results showed
that those who are listening who were
being talked to were actually those who
were deemed most powerful so listening
matters draw people in and listen to
their stories third stories persuade
stories can be a tool to advocate for
your ideas your cause your company
anything that's important to you stories
persuade and they move people to action
and when study researchers wanted to
know how to best raise funds for Save
the Children which is a nonprofit
focused on the well-being of children
worldwide they created two conditions
and they ran two versions of the app in
the first version of the ad they
provided statistics about the problems
facing children in Africa in the second
version of the ad they told the story of
a seven-year-old girl who faced
significant problems
her name was Rukia she was from Mali and
then they asked individuals after the
study whether they wanted to donate
money to save the children the results
showed that the individuals in the story
condition donated twice as much as those
who read about the statistics
there are four characteristics of an
effective story first
goal why are you telling the story in
the first place second grab attention
why would the audience want to listen
third engage why would the audience care
fourth enable action why would the
audience want to share the story these
are the four elements of a good story
and the story's goal is defined by where
you want the audience to go the
destination of the audience your goal
clarifies why you're telling the story
in the first place and when you develop
your goal you should know what is it
that you want the audience to do feel or
think after they heard your story it's
not just important to know where you
want the audience to land after the
story you also need to know where they
started from what is that they're
thinking about right now before you tell
them the story so it's both the
destination where you're taking them as
well as the journey for example with
Robert
he knew that he needed to get 20,000
South Asians into the registry within
weeks but he also knew that the
individuals he was to sharing a story
with had a misperception about how hard
it was to get into the registry so
therefore he had a debunk the myths
about the bone marrow registry and how
hard it is to get into it and how hard
it is to do a bone marrow transfer if
you're lucky enough to match so he had
to know where the audience was and where
he wanted them to go the second thing
you need to grab attention with a hook
why would someone listen to your story
oftentimes the most effective tool you
have is in fact the hook and it could be
a shocking statistic a dramatic pause a
funny joke why is it someone's even
looking and listening to your story
third engage what makes the story
compelling relatable a
entik why would an audience care once
you do share the story with them and the
answer that question is to what degree
do you have a protagonist who wants
something who has conflict and there is
an emotional roller coaster that you're
feeling as you listen to the story and
so the key characteristics of a good
story that's engaging compelling and
relatable are is there a protagonist
does he or she wants something
there must be an arc the journey that
the protagonist goes on for example in
Roberts story he made sure that Sameer
who was the protagonist was relatable he
even had Sameer blog through the whole
process so that people felt like they
knew Sameer and Robert didn't just talk
about the highs of the journey
he also blogged and talked about the
lows of the journey so that anyone
reading Sameer story would feel like
they were going on a journey with them
forth
how are you enabling action how are you
making it so that the story can be
shared or co-created with others in the
case of Robert he made the ability to
join the story abundantly easy clear and
even fun on the website they made tools
and templates that people could download
and be able to use at their
organizations to run their own bone
marrow drives other individuals started
adding their stories to Sameer stories
and in that process this story groove
how do you craft your story
everyone needs a signature story it's a
story that after you tell it people who
listen to it somehow look at you
differently and the most powerful
signature stories are those that take
the audience where you want them to go
one of the most powerful signature
stories is the vision story the vision
story is about where you want to go for
many of us there's a gap between how we
see ourselves and where we're going
versus how others see you and where
you're going
story is one of the most effective ways
to close that gap the story brings other
people along on your journey test your
signature story with multiple audiences
when was there a ha moment and what part
of the story made the aha moment happen
what did they take away from your story
if they had a title your story what
would they title it as the story will
evolve over time and in different
situations you're going to need a
portfolio of stories
when you take this inventory of stories
notice two things first which stories
might you want to stop telling they're
not useful for you anymore
the second is what are new stories that
you need to cultivate or Bank what are
stories that might allow you to address
a potential gap where others see you in
a way that you don't see yourself can
you populate that gap with new stories
that help bring others along with you I
was the first person in my immediate
family to go to college I grew up in the
city of Detroit and I went to an Ivy
League school where most people where I
grew up don't have the opportunity to go
now I'm a senior tech executive and I
get to work with lots of entrepreneurs
and I give them lots of advice and when
I tell them my story of how I took big
risks to get where I am it really
resonates with them it's really
important in my career that I'm seen as
innovative and it's not very innovative
to just tell someone that you're
innovative so I like to tell a story of
when I was in the renewable energy
industry and I applied for these federal
tax credits that historically had never
been used for solar or renewable energy
before we ended up being awarded twenty
million dollars in these tax credits and
we're able to deploy solar to low-income
communities throughout the Bay Area and
the story shows how I innovate instead
of just telling people I'm an innovator
so I became a mom nine years ago and
after a great pregnancy and a great
delivery
the unexpected happened and I began to
hemorrhage luckily I was in the care of
great providers and I had the care that
I needed at the right time but when I
was trying to understand why this
complication happened to me in the weeks
that followed I came across some
startling information which was that
half a million plus women were dying
every year from pregnancy and childbirth
related complications such as mine and
that my complication was actually one of
the leading causes of maternal mortality
I needed to share this information with
people and the statistics themselves are
incredibly powerful and always get
people to pay attention but when I talk
about my own experience
it gets people to pay attention in a
different kind of way suddenly people
understand that
oh this isn't something that only
happens to women in very impoverished
places in the world this happens
everywhere this happens in New York City
this happens in the United States and
happens two to three times a day in the
United States in fact that information
is powerful stories can be very
effective in different contexts for
instance I was in a negotiation with a
young woman the other day who started
the conversation with my mother once
told me and I was blown away she really
took the time to make a personal
connection in order to ask for what she
really wanted so my advice to you is to
find a way to be memorable make that
personal connection tell a story I think
one of the most important things is to
really be authentic not just for
yourself but really being authentic is
the best way to make a deep connection
with others and to bring people in it's
very hard to stand apart if you don't
let yourself be somewhat vulnerable and
I think when women are afraid of being
vulnerable it can it can really put
people at a distance so I think you know
what I would encourage you to do is to
is to be authentic and let yourself be
vulnerable an action you can take is to
write down your goals for this month
this year and for the next five years
and then consider what is a signature
story that might allow you to achieve
one of those goals a signature story is
a story that you've told over and over
again most likely it's a story that when
you share it others look at you slightly
differently and it's a story that moves
you closer to the goals that you might
hold so I think because I came from a
career that had associations attached
that you know clichés and stereotypes I
was a bit of baggage that I that I you
know that I'll carry for a while but
because my advocacy has always been so
rooted in personal experience that's my
most powerful tool talking the truth
from an experience and a perspective
that that no one else may have and then
I have the knowledge
expertise now to be able to add on the
data and the facts and the statistics
and so that of course makes my story
even more compelling but I start with
the truth I start with my experience and
I know that that's an effective way to
tell a story
stories are a great tool to get people
to understand you but you have to make
sure that you're telling the right story
to the right person at the right time
for it to have the impact that you want
it to have story is also a mindset and
it influences how you go about your day
instead of coding things as good or bad
things that happen to you you code these
events as highs and lows part of a story
and this can have dramatic impact I took
on a role to lead our operations in
India and when I got there people were
coming to me asking questions like why
do Americans think that we're only good
at call centers and back-end programming
and I said to them you guys are smart
but you have to be the one who shows
them something different you have to
shift the mindset and as I walked away
from some of those conversations I said
wait I have to do the same thing here I
was in this role where most people who
fill it are white men and I'm this black
woman and I knew I was just as smart as
they are so in shifting my mindset I was
able to show that I team that I was as
effective leader as anyone could be in
life there's signal and there's noise
the stories that you tell yourselves and
that others tell about you are the
signal to be effective you're going to
need to cut through the noise you're
going to have to engender confidence in
you and your vision stories help you do
that build your portfolio of signature
stories one day you're going to need
them so go out share stories and move
people to action